bei uns ist jetzt wieder Wolfgang
Richter der mit uns gemeinsam hier die
Lage einschätzt und er ist wieder bei
uns und die erste Frage jetzt auch in
Bezug ganz aktuell eben auf die Krim was
wir auch gerade von Dara Hassani gehört
haben die Frage kommt von IX Mack bei
Youtube er oder sie möchte wissen wie
realistisch ist es dass die Ukraine
innerhalb dieses Jahres die Landbrücke
zur Krim die Halbinsel selbst oder gar
den Zustand vor Februar 22 erreichen
könnte
also aus meiner Sicht ist das in diesem
Jahr ein sehr ambitioniertes Ziel und
ich kann mir eigentlich im Moment wenig
vorstellen dass es erreichbar ist wir
haben ja vorhin schon mal analysiert
welche Ressourcen beide Seiten haben wir
haben über die Verluste gesprochen
amerikanisch und britische Geheimdienste
haben sie Ende letzten Jahres bereits
auf jeweils 120.000
beziffert das schließt natürlich
verwundete ein und muss immer davon
ausgehen dass 20 bis 25% dann gefallen
sind aber das ist so eine Größenordnung
hinzu kommen noch 30 bis 40.000
Verluste die unendliche wie im Moment
etwas geringer aber ich glaube das
dürfte dann realistischer sein wenn man
auf diese Zahl kommt und insofern
wird wahrscheinlich Kriegsverlauf dazu
führen dass es noch weitaus höhere
Verluste gibt ohne dass man die
operationsziele erreicht und äh das
erste war ja genannt worden also die
Frage ob man den Korridor durchschneiden
sehen kann das müsste dann schon eine
sehr wuchtige Bewegung sein noch haben
die Ukrainer Reserven die sie
zurückhalten mit der sie wohl wenn Sie
die Schwachstelle gefunden haben dann
auch durchstoßen wollen aber auch das
sollte man nicht überbewerten denn auf
der russischen Seite stehen eben auch
Reserven übrigens sehr großer Zahl
mittlerweile die ja wohl auch ihrerseits
einen Gegenangriff planen sollte sich
die ukrainische gegen Offensive
festfressen also das ist ein
ambitioniertes Unternehmen natürlich
wenn es gelänge das asozial mehr zu
erreichen dann wäre die Landverbindung
zur Krim durchtrennt das heißt sie wäre
logistisch nur noch über die Brücke von
Kersch oder auch über den Seeweg
sicherzustellen und oder über den
Luftweg und das würde natürlich schon
ein erheblichen ein eine erhebliche
Einbuße bedeuten und die ganze Lage auf
der Krämpfe die Russen natürlich auch
sehr gefährlich macht sie werden also
alles versuchen den Korea zu halten
die weiteren Ziele die sie jetzt genannt
haben also ein die Krim zurückzuobern
die wurden schon vor mehreren Wochen
selbst von Amerikanern die es sicherlich
auch vernünftig bewertet haben in Frage
gestellt unter anderem vom Außenminister
blinken aber auch vom Generalstab statt
Melli das heißt da war er die Frage
gestellt worden ob man so nah an die
Creme heran kommt dass man dann
möglicherweise über weitreichende Waffen
oder durch den Einsatz weitreichender
Waffen entsprechende depotsflugplätze
etc oder auch helfen angreifen kann um
dann diese Situation um haltbar zu
machen das wäre jetzt zumindest operativ
gesehen ein sicherlich
ein Ziel dass man erreichen könnte denn
es gab ja schon solche Angriffe auf
bestimmte Plätze in der Krems das Ziel
die territuale Integrität
herzustellen im gesamten das ist ein
Ziel dass er der Präsident ausgegeben
hat das glaube ich ist offen gesagt
nicht erreichbar außer es würde das
Eintreten was ja in der Geschichte immer
wieder vorkam also eine Entwicklung die
unabs selber oder unvorhersagbar ist
weil sich plötzlich etwas ganz anderes
ereignet hat nicht ein Durchbruch an der
Front sondern zum Beispiel eine
innenpolitische Destabilisierung das
berühmte Beispiel ist die
Oktoberrevolution von 1917 im Ersten
Weltkrieg in Russland und nicht umsonst
hat vor dem Jahr auf diese Revolution
Bezug genommen nach diesem kurzaufstand
von trigoshi das ist aber jetzt kein
Thema mehr wahrscheinlich dort
so dass ich davon ausgehe dass so eine
Entwicklung schwarze Schwänze wenn man
ja auch sagt er unwahrscheinlich ist
bleibt dann noch die Frage könnte man
diese Situation vom 24 Februar letzten
Jahres wieder erreichen das hängt eng
mit der Frage der territualen Integrität
allerdings zusammen da bin ich auch
etwas skeptisch und ein Punkt den
sollten wir nicht übersehen bei all
diesen Spekulationen über das was
erreichbar ist natürlich ist die
ukrainische Kampfmoral ungeheuer hoch
und das ist ja bewunderungswürdig wie
hoch sie ist und die ukrainische
Identität ist gewachsen und wenn es ein
Geburtshelfer gab der die Zweifel an der
Existenz und der Identität der
ukrainischen Nation nun beseitigt hat
dann war es Putin selbst er hat dazu
beigetragen aber es gibt natürlich
Bevölkerungsteile wenn auch eine
Minderheiten die in diesen in diese
Nationalität oder nationale Identität
nicht eingeschlossen sind und das sind
die Kämpfer auf der anderen Seite die ja
verfassungsgemäß eigentlich auch
Ukrainer sind also das erste und zweite
Chor aus Lukas kommt jetzt mit den
Familien wir sprechen hier über etwa
35.000 Soldaten wir sprechen über
Angehörige der früheren ukrainischen
Schwarzmeerflotte die schon 2014
übergelaufen sind und jetzt auf der
anderen Seite denen und wir sprechen
natürlich auch über die Affinitäten die
es in diesem östlichen und südlichen
Randbereichen gibt man kann sie ja nicht
alle als Operateure behandeln das wusste
man auch schon bei den Minsk Abkommen
das heißt man muss auch dafür eine
Lösung finden um nicht anschließend
selbst wenn das alles gelänge dieser
Ambitionen dann einen anderen
Guerillakrieg zu bekommen der dann
umgekehrt geführt wird nämlich aus sich
dieser Minderheit also das ist dann eben
auch noch zu lösen aber wenn man alles
zusammenzieht unterm Strich da wird es
so sein dass die Ukraine alles tun
werden und sollten ihre
Verhandlungsposition zu verbessern dass
der Krieg durch die Schlacht entschieden
wird als ich jetzt im Moment aus
heutiger Sicht für ihre unterscheidet
sie haben gerade angesprochen die
Ukraine alles dafür tun wird ihre
Verhandlungsposition zu verbessern es
gab eine Meldungen in den letzten Tagen
die hat auch horchen lassen und zwar
haben US-Medien berichtet über den
Besuch von CIA Direktor burns in der
Ukraine das war aber wohl dann schon
einige Tage vorher das ist aber jetzt
eben erst rausgekommen berichtet worden
und dem nach also laut dieser US-Medien
Berichte glaubt Kiew also bis zum Herbst
beträchtliche Gebiete zurückerobern zu
können und was passiert dann dann soll
Artillerie und Raketensysteme in der
Nähe der von Russland kontrollierten
Krim verlegt werden und wenn dann es
soweit gekommen wäre so heißt es in dem
berichten dann würde man mit versuchen
mit Moskau dann doch Verhandlungen
aufzunehmen und das klang er jetzt
wirklich immer ausgeschlossen ist das
denn ihrer Meinung nach ein
realistisches Szenario also sind da
wirklich Verhandlung denkbar wenn der
Präsident also gestern noch sagt ohne
die Krim ist kein Ende des Krieges zu
machen
naja es gab ja mal eine Situation wo auf
der Präsident letztlich ja schon
zugestimmt hat dass es auch andere
Lösungen gibt ich erinnere an den
Vorschlag diese Zwischenlösung die er
von den Verhandlungsdelegationen nach 29
März letzten Jahres in Istanbul
vorgestellt worden waren da war die
Lösung dass man erstens auf die auf den
NATO-Beitritt verzichtet zweitens die
den Status den politischen Status der
Krim um 15 Jahre hinausschiebt und dann
eine Lösung zu finden aber das heißt ja
auch de facto Anerkennung der russischen
Kontrolle für 15 Jahre nicht der Jura
also nicht rechtlich gesehen aber
immerhin das ist schon eine andere
Situation und dann sollten die
Präsidenten direkt über ein Sonderstatus
des von was verhandelt das hört sich so
nach links 3 also weil Sonderrechte und
spezialrechte eingeräumt worden wären
und der vierte Punkt ohne jetzt
Universum und alles andere noch zu
erwähnen wäre die Frage der
Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine
gewesen eine Frage die natürlich heute
wieder ganz viral und wie auch nächste
Woche sicherlich in Vilnius zur Sprache
kommen wird aber diese
Verhandlungsposition sind ja schon
einmal zumindest vorläufig von den
autorisierten Delegationen akzeptiert
worden und sie sind allerdings jetzt
überholt worden sie sind überholt worden
zum Beispiel im September letzten Jahres
durch die an die weiteren Annexionen die
Russland vorgenommen hat das hat
natürlich die Tür für Verhandlung
zunächst einmal geschlossen aber der
Druck unter dem man jetzt dann steht
wenn die Operation nicht zum Erfolg
kommen also die Gegend Offensive und
wenn man vor der Wahl steht muss man
wieder verhandeln oder soll man noch
weitere zigtausende von Toten in Kauf
nehmen ich glaube dann wird irgendwann
sich die werkschale zugunsten der
Verhandlungen neigen hinzukommen ja auch
die Risiken die es gibt den wenn man
einen sicheren einen langfristigen Krieg
an einem langfristigen Krieg orientiert
dann muss man auch sicher gehen dass
langfristig die politische aber auch
frischer und logistischer Unterstützung
des Westens aufrechterhalten bleibt dazu
gibt es zwar jetzt natürlich die feste
Entschlossenheit der westlichen
Staatschefs aber wir wissen ja nicht was
die Risiken in Zukunft sein werden und
es geht schon mal los mit dem
Präsidentschaftswahlen im nächsten Jahr
in den USA und ich erinnere daran wenn
ein Präsident wie Donald Trump noch
einmal an die Regierung kommt oder ein
ähnlich gearteter Präsidenten kann sich
diese Lage schon wieder verändern all
das zusammengenommen spricht nicht
unbedingt dafür dass ein langer Krieg
zugunsten der Ukraine ausgehen muss oder
für das ukrainische Volk Mann von
Vorteil wäre sondern ich glaube dass der
Druck zu verhandeln schon steigen wird
und das wird sich in den nächsten Wochen
herausstellen wenn man sieht welche
Ressourcen aufeinander treffen und wie
schwierig es sein wird irgendwelche
größeren Erfolge sprechen nicht von
kleineren Bewegungen an der Front die
wird immer geben aber ich meine wirklich
strategisch Erfolge zu erzählen
es gibt Kommentare dazu und Fragen im
Stream Manfred peumer Pollmer richtig ja
kommentiert auf Facebook ich bin immer
noch der Meinung der einzige Weg um den
Krieg zu beenden sind ernsthafte
Verhandlungen möge die Voraussetzungen
noch so schwierig sein jeder Tote ist
einer zu viel und es gibt viele Fragen
jetzt gerade auch in Bezug auf die
aktuelle Offensive ich möchte die so ein
bisschen bündeln dann können Sie das in
einer Antwort vielleicht zusammenfassen
es gibt einmal die Frage von Poki Frosch
er fragt bei Youtube welches Ziel hatte
die Offensive dann fragt icke was
spricht denn dafür dass diese gegen
Offensive noch ein Erfolg werden könnte
und dann auch hier noch zusammengefasst
mit der Frage von Maximilian Benzinger
was würde eine gescheiterter Offensive
für die Ukraine bedeuten wäre dass der
Anfang vom Ende also was war das Ziel
dann was spricht dafür dass noch was
werden könnte und was bedeutet ein
Misserfolg
ja das erklärte Ziel das politische Ziel
zumindest ist die Wiederherstellung der
territoren Integrität das hat die
ukrainische Regierung immer wieder
betont ich glaube dass das Militär da
etwas nüchterner denkt und sagt das
operative Ziel müsste es eigentlich sein
den Korridor zu durchtrennen der die
Creme und den Don Bass verbindet
möglichst also ein Vorstoß bis zu der
Küste das auch schon Meeres und zum
anderen natürlich auch die russischen
starken Stellungen und Truppen im
Dornbach soweit zurückzubringen dass
auch die Russen unter Druck geraten das
wäre ein militärisch zumindest eher
erreichbares Ziel was spricht für ein
Erfolg der Gegend Offensive war die
Frage Nummer zwei
ich meine es bleibt glaube ich bei den
grundsätzlichen Einschätzung dass die
Kamera der Ukraine wirklich besonders
Wert ist das muss man eindeutig sagen
dass sie auch ihre taktischen Operation
gut koordinieren kann dass sie sehr gut
Aufklärung und Drohnen aufeinander
abstimmen was sie aber noch nicht
gezeigt haben das ist größere
angriffsbewegungen gut zu koordinieren
da sind sie noch in einem Hybriden
System das teilweise noch sowjetisch
denkt und teilweise NATO-Standards
übernommen hat sie sind noch nicht ganz
dort bei westlichen Vorstellungen
das ist nur an den Mitteln liegt glaube
ich nicht denn die Ukraine hatten wir
von Beginn an eine sehr sehr starke
Armee die Russen sind große riesigen
eingegangen gegen eine sehr starke auch
panzerstarke Armee vorzugehen es war die
zweitstärkste in Europa nach den Russen
und sie haben natürlich die Quittung
erhalten weil sie die Risiken völlig
unterschätzt haben mittlerweile haben
sie allerdings gelernt
und die Russen machen diese großen
Fehler nicht mehr die sie am Anfang
gemacht haben aber Sie haben immer noch
ein paar Dinge die Sie einfach nicht
hinkriegen zum Beispiel die Initiative
auf der unteren Führungsebene sie fehlt
völlig das haben die Ukraine sehr gut
drauf
auch teilweise noch immer Mängel in der
Koordinierung des Defekt verbunden
generell sind jetzt besser geworden
und auf der operativen Ebene sind die
Ukrainer noch nicht dort wo sie sein
müssten um so eine Operation wirklich
erfolgreich zu führen und das hängt
nicht nur damit zusammen dass es
bestimmte Waffensysteme noch brauchte
diese eventuell zu wenig haben also die
Flugabwehr der Bodentruppen die im
Angriff sind sie haben da einiges sie
haben eigene System und sie haben die
Geparden etc die mitfahren mit der
Truppe aber da kann man natürlich noch
mehr tun das ist völlig klar das wird
man immer sagen in einem Gefecht wir
brauchen mehr aber es ist nicht so dass
generell diese diese Elemente fehlen
aber Sie müssen halt gut koordiniert
werden und das spricht alles dafür dass
sie vielleicht noch Teil Erfolge
erzielen aber nicht den ganz großen
strategischen Rücken und dann die letzte
Frage was bedeutet eine gescheiterte
Offensive eine gescheiterte Offensive
muss natürlich nicht bedeuten dass das
Ende der Ukraine wäre es kann genauso
gut sein dass der Krieg sich da mehr
oder mindert das vielleicht die Russen
noch ein paar Gelände Gewinne machen
dass sie aber auch die Russen ja vor dem
Dilemma jetzt weitere Eroberung halten
zu müssen
mehr Verluste noch mal einzuplanen ihre
eigene Stellung auch gegenüber der NATO
lässt sich zu schwächen das darf man
nicht ganz vergessen Sie werden aus
diesem Krieg herauskommen mit
geschwächten und überdehnten
Landstreitkräften und das ist auch keine
so ganz gute Nachricht weil damit
natürlich auch der Fokus eher auf
Nuklearwaffen liegt wenn es also um die
NATO geht also die aus russischer Sicht
die Defensive gegen die NATO auf eine
sehr sehr langen Frontlinie die jetzt
vom Nordkap runter reicht nach dem
finnischen Beitrag über die baltischen
Staaten bis runter nach zum Schwarzen
Meer das sind alles Überlegung und die
natürlich auch eine Rolle spielen ich
glaube eher dass die Russen dann wohl
ihre
bis jetzt bis jetzt besetzten Gebiete
halten vielleicht auch noch ausweiten
wollen ich würde auch nicht ausschließen
dass sie noch versuchen einen Stoß nach
Odessa durchzuführen wenn es ihm gelingt
noch mal über den Körper zu kommen das
alles ist denkbar aber die Ukraine
generell zu beherrschen halte ich für
unmöglich und ich glaube dass das auch
keiner mit Realität sind im russischen
generalsta plant weil man natürlich ganz
genau weiß dass der ukrainische
Widerstand dann eben auch auf viele
Jahrzehnte wahrscheinlich erhalten
bleibt und das ist nicht beherrschbar
Arthur Fritzlar kommentiert zur
Gegenoffensive hier bei uns bei Youtube
das geht über Monate und Monate was
erwartet man in Wochen ohne
Luftunterstützung läuft dann nichts und
Chris Watts schreibt wie sollen die
Ukraine gegen befestigte Stellung mit
Minenfeldern Vorgehen die Russen haben
auch Drohnen und beobachten jede
Bewegung mit Bradley und Mardern ist da
kein Durchkommen wenn wir darüber
sprechen über diese Lufthoheit der
Russen also hier Helikopter Kampfjets
Drohnen die das Fortkommen ja ganz klar
erschweren also der ukrainischen Armee
ist da nicht natürlich der Folge
richtige Schluss der Ukraine zu fordern
klar sie brauchen Kampfjets klar sie
brauchen da jetzt mehr Unterstützung ist
überhaupt ohne diese Unterstützung aus
dem Westen noch was zu erreichen
wenn sie auf die Angriff
angriffsfähigkeit hinaus wollen ich sage
noch einmal die die verschiedenen
Elemente die man braucht für das Gefecht
verbundener Waffen und für operative
Angriffe sind im Prinzip vorhanden man
kann nie davon genug haben im Klaren
Gefecht muss man immer mehr haben aber
die Koordinierung glaube ich ist
wichtiger als alles andere es ist nicht
so dass die Ukrainer keine Luftwaffe
hätten sie haben eine sie ist sogar ganz
erfolgreich im Einsatz gesetzt
mittlerweile britische weitreichende
Shadow man kann sie eben auch unter die
mit 29 also ein eher ein Modell das ja
auf sowjetischer Bauarbeiten das sind
alles Dinge die macht was sind die F16
ist ein kampflokzeug das wird sehr lange
dauern es wird wahrscheinlich in diesem
Jahr kaum noch in den Einsatz gehen
können
aus dem User nämlich dazu warum bekommt
die Ukraine die F16 erst nach der
Offensive die Flieger wären doch jetzt
viel wichtiger
also zunächst mal sie haben selbst
Kampfhubschrauber und auch
Kampfflieger die F16 kann nicht sofort
in den Einsatz gehen selbst wenn sie
jetzt verfügbar wäre weil einfach die
Vorbereitungszeit zu lange dauert die
Piloten müssen völlig ungeschult werden
das dauert Monate das beginnt ja jetzt
erst die Logistik muss müsste
bereitgestellt werden ein Kampfflugzeug
ist nur so gut wie die Logistik die ist
dann auch da das ja nur wenige Stunden
gibt die sie fliegen können also die
Logistik ist ganz wichtig die Wartung
die Ersatzteile und vor allen Dingen die
Munition das Kampfflugzeug ist ja immer
nur die eine Seite der Diskussion die
andere Seite ist wie sind sie
ausgerüstet welche Munition haben Sie
welche Aufklärungsmittel haben sie wie
gut ist die Luftraum Überwachung dort
und das Luftlage Bild all das ist
wichtig und auch die die Führung
sozusagen der kampflieger vom Boden aus
in Richtung Feind oder über die Frage
also der entsprechenden Radarsysteme
auch der Aufklärung die über den Westen
natürlich teilweise läuft all das erst
macht Sinn also nicht über ein einzelnes
System zu reden das Gesamtsystem ist
auch hier wieder entscheidend es wird
nicht mehr rechtzeitig kommen in diesem
Jahr da bin ich glaube ich
einig mit vielen anderen Beobachtern die
sagen es
die Zeit wird dafür nicht reichen also
frühestens Ende des Herbst könnten die
ersten dann erscheinen dann muss man die
Ressourcen miteinander vergleichen oder
wie viel Kampfflugzeuge reden wird die
russische Luftwaffe hatte zu Beginn 1300
Kampfflugzeuge insgesamt natürlich nicht
alle in der Ukraine ist
selbstverständlich sie haben viele
andere Bereiche diese weiter schützen
müssen trotzdem bleibt die Überlegenheit
deutlich wenn man sieht dass die Ukraine
zu Beginn 125 hatten also
10 % davon aber alle im Einsatz können
natürlich und diese Verluste müssen
ausgeglichen werden und wir reden im
Moment vielleicht über 30 40
16 das ist nicht die strategische Größe
die man bräuchte und jetzt große
strategische Umbrüche zu erreichen das
soviel zur ich glaube was wichtiger
Moment ist ist den eigenen Luftraum
durch Abwehr also durch Raketen und
Flugabwehr in den Griff zu bekommen da
kann man noch mehr tun da hat aber auch
selenski deutlich gemacht dass zum
Beispiel Systeme wieder ihre Steak ganz
hervorragend wird aber auch Patrick die
ja immerhin schon geschafft haben selbst
diese angeblichen Wunderwaffen also die
kindscheibe pauschal Raketen dann zu
bekämpfen erfolgreich zu bekämpfen also
auch das mit ein bisschen Abstand als
würde eine weitere Frage gestellt das
hat was mit dem Drohnen sofort die
Drohnen da muss man unterscheiden
zwischen den Drohnen die man an der
Front einsetzt zur Aufklärung und zur
unmittelbaren Koordination mit der
Artillerie Bekämpfung das machen wir
Ukraine ganz hervorragend davon haben
sie auch sehr viel und da haben sie sehr
viel auch vom Westen bekommen das ist
glaube ich einer der stärken
mindest um strategische Bohnen geht oder
sagen wir mal weitreichende Drohnen die
dann eher operative zähle im Hinterland
angreifen oder Gaststätte dann haben sie
natürlich nicht diese vergleichbaren
Waffen aber was wäre denn dann das Ziel
dann wäre das Ziel also auf russische
Stellung in Russland oder russische
Städte eben auch an zu fliegen und das
würde ja zwar eine Eskalation bedeuten
es hat ja teilweise Angriffe gegeben
aber es würde an der Front nicht viel
verändert also man muss dann schon den
Blick tatsächlich für die Front haben
und insofern ich schick mal die eine
Frage zu den Minenfelder noch mit rein
die Minenfelder sind ein typisches
Beispiel dafür dass man nicht den Krieg
dadurch betrachten darf durch die Linse
eines Waffensystems das war von Anfang
an ein bisschen schief auch in der
öffentlichen Darsteller es sind nicht
die einzelnen Waffensysteme die
entscheiden sind selbst wenn es ganz
wichtig ist dass man überlegen was man
System hat daran hat
ja darauf hingewiesen das ist in der Tat
beim Leoparden nicht so viel
personalverluste gibt selbst wenn er
getroffen worden ist kommt das Personal
leichter raus weil die Munition zum
Beispiel getrennt gelagert wird und
nicht neben dem Personal das sind alles
Dinge die eine Rolle spielen aber sie
spielen keine entscheidende Rolle für
die Frage wie man Operation am Ende
führt und gewinnt der dazu muss man
alles Systeme haben die nötig sind um
eben durch Minenfelder dann möglichst
Rascheln durchzukommen also wie ein
Panzer aber auch anderes minenräumgerät
dass man beispielsweise fern verstehst
am Schneisen zu schlagen und natürlich
auch ähm selbst die Fähigkeit
gleichzeitig zu haben Männer schnell zu
verlegen über Minenwerfer wenn es darum
geht die eigenen Flanken Gegenangriffe
zu schützen und das sind jetzt nur
Beispiele wir müssen also alles Systeme
immer in Kombination sehen von der
Artillerie über die infanterien Schützen
fahren sondern über die Kampfpanzer die
Pioniere die ja beides machen die
Bewegung vorbereiten die überflüsse
setzen können die die Minenfelder legen
aber sie haben also das sind Dinge die
zusammengehören und selbstverständlich
die Flugabwehr um solche Operation
überhaupt erst möglich zu machen und was
natürlich neben dem Material neben den
Waffensystem eine große Rolle spielt wie
viele Menschen habe ich mit denen ich da
in den Kampf ziehen die die bedienen
können deswegen ganz zum Schluss noch
die Frage an Sie aus dem Stream wie viel
man könnte die Ukraine noch realistisch
mobilisieren das spielt ja eine Rolle
wenn jetzt immer mehr Soldaten an der
Front verwendet werden
also ich glaube es gibt durchaus noch
reservepersonal in der Ukraine das auch
noch mobilisiert werden kann es gibt
Angaben vom Institut für strategische
Studien vom internationalen Institut für
strategische Studien in London die die
etwa bei 400.000 Mann beziffern die
Frage ist allerdings in der Tat wie
viele werden jetzt unabhängig noch
unabhängig gestellt muss man dafür also
andere Regeln jetzt haben damit man auch
mehr Personal gewinnt und ich fand das
schon bemerkenswert das mittlerweile
rekrutierungs-teams durch odesser gehen
und Leute auf der Straße ansprechen ob
sie sich nicht mal melden wollen also
das sind dann Männer im mittleren Alter
so haben die 40 oder bisschen drunter
bisschen drüber also die ganz große
Begeisterung scheint nicht mehr da zu
sein aber doch noch sicherlich ein sehr
sehr hohes Maß und auch
opferungswellen das muss man den
Ukrainern wirklich unter wann das in ein
Zustand des Fatalismus übergeht wenn die
Erfolge ausbleiben das kann man jetzt im
Moment nur spekulieren aber ich
befürchte dass irgendwann der Punkt
kommt wo man sagt ja klar ich bleibe
loyal zu meinem Land aber ich habe keine
große Hoffnungen mehr und ich hoffe dass
dieser Punkt nicht insofern
durchschlagen ist dass es dann zur
größeren Einbußen kommen sondern dass
die Politik das rechtzeitig erkennt und
sagt jetzt wird es aber Zeit eine andere
Lösung vielleicht über Verhandlung dann
auch
zu
bewerkstelligen Einschätzung von Oberst
Adi Wolfgang Richter vielen lieben Dank
dafür dass sie so viel Zeit für uns
heute hatten danke